>>> YOU JUST TAPPED INTO THE
GROUP CHAT LIVE IN THE BLEACHER
REPORT APP PRESENTED BY FAN
DUEL.
I'M GREG ALONGSIDE LIV.
ARE YOU EXCITED FOR NBA
BASKETBALL THIS WEEK?
>> I AM.
I'M EXCITED TO GIVE OUT PICKS.
IT'S THE SEASON OF GIVING AND
CHARLES BARKLEY AND FAN DUEL ARE
ALSO IN THE GIVING SPIRIT AS
WELL.
THEY'VE TEAMED UP TO GIVE AWAY
OVER $7 MILLION IN GIFTS TO FAN
DUEL CUSTOMERS THROUGH DECEMBER
27th.
SO GET ON FAN DUEL AND LOOK FOR
ODDS BOOTH, SAME GAME PARLAYS,
SPECIALS AND MORE.
THE SEASON OF GIVING.
LET'S CATCH OUT.
HEAD TO THE FAN DUEL SPORTSBOOK.
>> IT IS THE SEASON OF GIVING.
WE'RE ALWAYS IN THE GIVING MOOD
HERE, LIV, ALWAYS IN THE GIVING
MOOD BUT IN THE HOLIDAY SPIRIT
WE'RE GIVING AWAY LOCKS, HOODIES
AND GIVING AWAY JERSEYS TODAY SO
PLEASE, GET IN THE COMMENTS.
I NEED GIFS, EMOJIS BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY, I NEED WINNERS
ONLY.
PLEASE TYPE IT OUT IF YOU GUYS
WANT -- ACTUALLY THE PRODUCER
JUST WHISPERED INTO MY EAR,
GREG, GIVE AWAY A HOODIE.
I AM IN THE COMMENTS RIGHT NOW,
LIV, GIVING AWAY HOODIES.
BR BET, SHOUT OUT TO YOU GUYS.
JAC
JACOB KEARNS TAKES THE LAKERS
OR -- OH, HE SAYS TWO THINGS.
LAKERS OR MAVS.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU'RE TELLING
TO US TAKE EITHER/OR BUT DOESN'T
MATTER, YOU ARE WALKING AWAY
WITH A HOODIE.
LIV, IT'S TUESDAY, TNT TUESDAY.
FAN DUEL IS BOOSTING THE 3x2 IN
BOTH GAMES MAKING IT 3xTUESDAY.
IT THERE BE A TWO-THREE-POINTERS
IN THE FIRST THREE MINUTES OF
THE GAME, THE LAST WEEK IN THE
WARRIORS/KNICKS GAME JUST LIKE
ME AND LIV TOLD Y'ALL, LET'S
TAKE A LOOK.
THERE IT IS.
YOU KNOW WHO THIS IS.
I CALL HIM THIRTY.
THERE IT IS FROM THE TOP, THAT
WAS THE TIE RIGHT THERE, THAT
WAS THE TIE AND THEN WE GOT THE
FORMER WARRIOR, ALEX BURT FROM
THE WING, YES, SIR, YES, SIR.
THE 3x2 CASHED EASILY LAST WEEK
AND TODAY WE ASKED YOU ON
TWITTER WHICH 3x2 WILL CASH
TONIGHT?
WILL IT BE THE PACERS TAKING ON
THE HEAT OR WILL IT BE THE SUNS
TAKING ON THE LAKERS?
HERE ARE THE CURRENT RESULTS.
OOH, WOW.
THAT WAS IMPRESSIVE.
THE PHOENIX SUNS AND THE LAKERS
IS WINNING THIS ONE BY A
LANDSLIDE.
I WOULD SAY, LIV, BOTH 3x2s ARE
IN PLUS MONEY.
WHICH ONE DO YOU LIKE THE BEST?
>> I PERSONALLY LIKE FADING THE
PUBLIC ON THIS ONE WHICH IS
EITHER A GOOD THING OR A BAD
THING, DEPENDING ON THE NIGHT
BUT I KIND OF LIKE RIDING WITH
THE PACERS AND THE HEAT IN THIS
ONE, BOTH PHOENIX AND THE LAKERS
GUARD THE THREE BETTER THAN BOTH
THE PACERS OWN THE HEAT.
THE HEAT ALLOWED THE THIRD MOST
THREES AND ALTHOUGH THEY'RE
MISSING QUITE A FEW GUYS
TONIGHT, THEY STILL HAVE DUNCAN
ROBINSON AND KYLE LOWERY WHO
WOULD HAVE CASHED THIS 3x2 IN
THE LAST GAME AGAINST THE PACERS
BECAUSE THEY EACH HAD A THREE
BEFORE THE FIRST THREE MINUTES
WAS UP.
I LIKE FADING THE PUBLIC HERE
BUT I'D LOVE TO KNOW HOW YOU
FEEL ABOUT IT.
>> YES, WE ALWAYS HAVE
INTERESTING STATS, INTERESTING
TAKES REGARDING THE 3x2 BUS BA
IT'S INTERESTING BET, TWO THREES
IN THE FIRST TWO MINUTES.
SEE WHAT THE PEOPLE ARE WRITING
IN THE COMMENTS.
BRBET IN THE COMMENTS,
SUNS/LAKERS FAVORING YOU, LIV
UNFORTUNATELY.
LANDON IS GOING WITH THE SUNS
LAKERS.
THEY'RE NOT FADING YOU.
WE'RE RIDING BOTH 3x2s, JUST
LEANING THE OTHER WAY.
SO THERE'S NO FADING ON HERE.
SHOUT OUT TO LANDON SHOUT OUT TO
BRBET.
KIRK SAYS THE SUNS IS A LOCK.
SUNS/LAKERS IS A LOCK SO IT IS
APPARENT.
WE ARE RIDING THE SUNS AND THE
LAKERS 3x2.
LIV, DON'T FEEL NO TYPE OF WAYS,
DON'T FEEL --
>> NO HARD FEELINGS.
>> NO ANIMOSITY, NO HARD
FEELINGS BECAUSE WE ARE ALSO
RIDING WITH INDIANA AND THE
MIAMI HEAT 3x2, SPRINKLE ON
BOTH.
WE WANT YOUR PLAYER POINT PICKS
FOR THE SUNS AND THE LAKERS
GAME.
GET IN THE COMMENTS AND TELL US
WHAT YOU GUYS THINK.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE CURRENT
ODDS, LIV.
WHAT DO YOU LIKE HERE?
>> SO I'M ACTUALLY LIKING TWO
PLAYS.
I'M REALLY LIKING JAE CROWDER,
OVER 9 1/2 POINTS TONIGHT.
13 POINTS THE LAST TIME THE TWO
TEAMS MET.
THE LAKERS ALLOWED THE FOURTH
MOST POINTS TO THAT POWER
FORWARD POSITION, AN AVERAGE OF
22 1/2 AND CROWDER HAS HIT THIS
OVER IN SIX OF THE LAST EIGHT.
I LIKE RUSSELL REST WESTBROOK
OVER 19 1/2 POINTS.
I THINK HE HAS A LOT MORE
OPPORTUNITIES TO GET SOME
BUCKETS HERE.
THE SUNS GIVE UP AN AVERAGE OF
23 POINTS TO THE OPPOSING POINT
GUARD SO I LIKE WESTBROOK TO
HAVE A NIGHT.
>> LIV LIKES RUSS TO HAVE A
NIGHT, LIV AND I THINK I'M GOING
TO PIGGYBACK WITH YOU SIMPLY
BECAUSE YOU MENTIONED THERE'S NO
A.D. SO WE KNOW WHAT BRODY LIKES
TO DO WHEN HE HAS TO BE THE GUY,
HE USUALLY STEPS UP TO THE PLATE
AND BECOMES AGGRESSIVE.
I THINK HE'S GOING TO BE REAL
AGGRESSIVE TONIGHT, SCORING THE
BALL AND PASSING THE BALL SO I'M
GOING TO GO WITH BRODY OVER
19 1/2 POINTS.
WE'RE GOING TO LOCK THAT ONE IN.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS.
I WANT TO SEE WHAT YOU GUYS ARE
TALKING ABOUT, CYRUS JOHNSON,
WATCH OUT FOR MONK ON THE
LAKERS.
OKAY, LIKE THE CURVEBALL THERE.
WES MILLER SAYS GIVE HIM BOOK
AND JAE WITH THE OVER.
HE'S ROCKING WITH YOU, LIV.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU WES.
I GOT ONE MORE IN ME, CAR LEASE
MU SAYS HAS CROWDER OVER NINE
POINTS AND D. BOOK OF COURSE.
HE'S ROCKING WITH CROWDER AND D.
BOOK.
SHOUT OUT TO EVERYBODY I
MENTIONED.
YOU GUYS ARE WALKING AWAY WITH
HOODIES.
LIV, MY FAVORITE PART OF THE
SHOW.
LET'S TALK MAJOR MARKETS MONEY
LINES AGAINST THE SPREADS AND
POINT TOTALS FOR TONIGHT'S GAME.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE ODDS,
LIV.
WHAT ARE YOU SEEING HERE AND
WHAT DO YOU LIKE?
>> YEAH, I LIKE OVER 224 1/2 IN
THAT PHOENIX/LAKERS GAME.
THESE ARE TWO TEAMS WITH TOP
FIVE PACE, OFFENSIVELY, BOTH OF
THESE TEAMS RANKED TOP TEN IN
POINTS SCORED PER GAME.
DEFENSIVELY THE LAKERS RANKED
BOTTOM FIVE IN POINTS ALLOWED
PER GAME SO I LIKE THIS TO BE A
HIGH-SCORING AFFAIR AND IF WE
ARE RIDING THAT 3x2 ON THIS
THREE-BY-TUESDAY, WE'RE GOING TO
CASH THAT THAT THE FIRST THREE
MINUTES.
LOTS OF BALLS SWISHING IN THE
NET.
I TAKE OVER 224 1/2.
>> LIV IS ROCKING WITH THE OVER
IN THAT GAME.
I LIKE THAT, LIV.
I LIKE THAT BECAUSE I DO SEE
THIS ONE BEING A HIGH-SCORING
AFFAIR.
RUSSELL WESTBROOK IS GOING TO BE
A LEADING THE WARRIORS TONIGHT
AND RUSS LIKES TO GET UP AND
DOWN THE COURT.
LET ME GIVE AWAY SOME HOODIES.
I WANT TO SEE WHAT THE PEOPLE
ARE RIDING WITH.
BR BET SOMETHING IN THE COMMENTS
SAYING LIV IS A SHARP, SHOUT OUT
TO BR BETTING.
MARK SAYS SUNS MINUS 6 1/2 TO
THE MOON.
HE'S TAKING THAT BET TO THE
MOON.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, MARK.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
KELLIE NOT UBRE, GUARANTEED
WESTBROOK TRIPLE-DOUBLE.
RUSS IS OUT THERE SCORING,
PASSING, REBOUNDING, SO SHOUT
OUT TO EVERYBODY THAT I
MENTIONED.
YOU ALL ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I'M GOING TO HOP IN HERE.
I'M GOING TO TAKE A LOOK AT THAT
INDIANA/MIAMI HEAT GAME.
I'M GOING TO ROCK WITH THE
INDIANA PACERS MONEY LINE,
SIMPLY BECAUSE THE HEAT ARE
SHORT-HANDED.
THEY HAVE A LOT OF INJURIES.
THEY HAVE A LOT OF INJURIES TO
THEIR TEAM THIS SEASON, A LOT OF
GUYS BOUNCING OUT LIKE FLIES,
JUMPING OUT LIKE FLIES SO I'M
GOING TO ROCK WITH THE PACERS
AND I'M GOING TO STAY MONEY
LINE.
I THINK THIS IS A CLOSE ONE.
LET'S PLAY IT SAFE, TAKE THE
MONEY LINE AND KEEP IT PUSHING,
MAN.
LET'S KEEP IT PUSHING.
WE TALK MAJOR MARKS, LIV.
LET'S TALK PLAYER PROPS.
TIME FOR LOCK OR NOT.
I'M GOING TO PUT UP A PROP AND I
NEED ALL OF YOU, I MEAN
EVERYBODY IN THE COMMENTS TO
TELL ME WHETHER IT IS A LOCK OR
IT IS NOT.
LIV, I KNOW YOU READY AND I KNOW
THE PEOPLE IN THE COMMENTS IS
READY.
>> READY.
>> SO LET'S JUST GET RIGHT TO
IT.
LET'S GET RIGHT TO IT.
FIRST UP MY MAN LeBRON JAMES, AS
THE LIL' KIDS SAY, WE GOT LeBRON
JAMES TO HAVE A DOUBLE-DOUBLE
TONIGHT, SITTING AT PLUS 110,
LIV.
DO YOU THINK THIS IS A LOCK OR
DO YOU THINK THIS IS NOT A LOCK?
>> I THINK IT'S A LOCK AND IF
YOU'RE LOOKING AT IT JUST FROM
LIKE A STORYLINE PERSPECTIVE, NO
A.D.
THE SUNS HANDLED BUSINESS
AGAINST THE LAKERS EARLIER THIS
SEASON.
LeBRON DOESN'T WANT THAT TO
HAPPEN AGAIN.
FROM MORE OF A STATISTICS
STANDPOINT HE HIT A
DOUBLE-DOUBLE IN THREE OF THE
LAST FIVE.
HE HAD 25 POINTS, FIVE ASSISTS
AND TWO REBOUNDS THE LAST TIME
HE PLAYED THE SUNS.
I THINK HIS BEST BET TO HIT A
DOUBLE-DOUBLE IS WITH POINTS AND
BOARDS AND BECAUSE A.D. IS OUT
IT GIVES HIM MORE OPPORTUNITIES
TO GET BOARDS AND SUNS TEAM
RANKS BOTTOM TEN IN REBOUNDS
ALLOWED TO OPPONENT.
POINTS AND BOARDS HE'S HITTING A
DOUBLE-DOUBLE SO I THINK IT'S A
LOCK.
>> LIV THINKS IT'S A LOCK.
I'M GOING TO FOLLOW HER, A LOCK,
TOO.
INSTEAD OF REBOUNDS, LIV, I WANT
YOU TO LOOK AT THE ASSISTS.
I WANT TO YOU LOOK AT THE
ASSISTS.
SOMEBODY MENTIONED, SOMEBODY
MENTIONED
RUSS' TRIPLE DOUBLE BUT POSSIBLY
OF LeBRON'S DRIPLE-DOUBLE.V.
OF LeBRON'S DRIPLE-DOUBLE.
NO A.D., HIGH-PACED GAME.
TALKING OVER.
I'M GOING WITH A LOCK HERE.
I'M GOING TO GO WITH A LOCK
HERE.
I WANT TO SEE WHAT YOU'RE
TALKING.
I'M IN THE HANDY DANDY iPAD
COMMENTS.
I GOT A.D., ADIXIX, IT'S LeBRON.
HE PUTS UP, LeBRON WANTS HIS
REVENGE AGAINST THE SUNS AND
CP3.
HE'S LOCKING IT IN.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, A.D., LOVE,
LOVE THE TAKE.
I GOT BRADY ROCKING WITH ME.
HE SAYS LeBRON JAMES
TRIPLE-DOUBLE IN ALL CAPS, LIV,
LOCK.
HE'S ROCKING WITH LeBRON JAMES
TO SCORE A TRIPLE-DOUBLE AND
LANDON FLOSS IS IN THE COMMENTS
SAYING HE COULD NOT AGREE WITH
YOU MORE, LIV, HE'S RIDING WITH
YOU.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
NEXT UP IS D. BOOK.
TO SCORE THREE OR MORE
THREE-POINTERS TONIGHT.
LIV, THIS IS ALSO PLUS MONEY
SITTING AT PLUS 124.
DO YOU THINK THIS IS A LOCK OR
DO YOU THINK THIS IS NOT?
>> I FEEL LIKE THE PUBLIC AND
THE COMMENTS SECTION IS NOT
GOING TO LIKE WHAT I HAVE TO SAY
BUT I DON'T THINK THIS IS A
LOCK.
I MEAN, THIS IS ONLY HIS SECOND
GAME BACK.
HE SHOT 33% FROM THE THREE THE
LAST TIME THAT HE PLAYED THE
LAKERS.
THE LAKERS' OWPPONENTS HAVE THE
SIXTH LOWEST THREE-POINT
PERCENTAGE.
THEY HAVE SOLID PERIMETER
DEFENSE.
LeBRON JAMES A REVENGE GAME FOR
HIM BUCKLE DOWN ON DEVIN BOOKER
WHO CAN SHOOT THE BALL AND DON'T
WANT D. BOOK TO GET HOT.
THAT MEANS TROUBLE FOR THE
LAKERS.
I LIKE THE DEFENSE TO BE TOUGH
ON HIM TONIGHT.
I ACTUALLY THINK THIS IS NOT A
LOCK.
I DON'T FEEL COMFORTABLE WITH IT
BUT I'D LOVE TO KNOW HOW YOU
FEEL ABOUT IT.
>> LIV, I'M GOING TO GO THE
OTHER WAY.
I'M GOING TO GO THE OTHER WAY
FOR A COUPLE REASONS.
WE MENTIONED THE FAST PACE UP
AND DOWN.
YOU LIKE THE OVER.
I THINK THIS WILL BE A
FAST-PACED GAME.
WE KNOW THE SUNS LIKE TO PLAY UP
AND DOWN THE COURT AND WE KNOW
THE LAKERS HAVE TO RUN WITH NO
A.D.
THIS IS A FAST-PACED BECAME.
USUALLY THAT MEANS MORE
THREE-POINTERS OR ATTEMPTED.
I LIKE THAT TREND AND THEN I
ALSO WANT TO TALK ABOUT HIS LAST
GAME.
HIS FIRST GAME BACK HE PUT UP
EIGHT THREES, LIV, A LOT, HE PUT
UP EIGHT THREES AND MADE FOUR.
SO HE'S PUTTING THEM UP.
HE'S THROWING THEM UP.
YOU CAN'T BE MAD, IF I'M BETTING
ON SOMEBODY TO MAKE THREES, I
WANT THEM TO CHUCK UP THREES, SO
YOU CAN'T BE MAD.
D. BOOK MIGHT BE CHUCKING UP
SOME THREES SO I'M GOING TO SAY
THIS ONE IS A LOCK AND I'M IN
THE COMMENTS NOW.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS.
I WANT TO SEE IF YOU GUYS THINK
THIS IS A LOCK OR NOT.
OH, THEY ARE ON YOUR SIDE.
I GOT KIRK OLLO756 SAYS NOT A
LOCK WITH A LOT OF STOP SIGNS
EMOJIS.
I GOT MONEY MERV IN THE COMMENTS
WITH A LOT OF Xs, NOT ROCKING
WITH IT.
THEY NOT ROCKING WITH D. BOOK,
MAN.
THEY ON YOUR SIDE, LIV, THEY
ROCKIN' WIT YOU.
BUT --
>> MAYBE CROWDER WILL GET THOSE
THREES.
THAT'S WHEAT I NEED FOR THE OVE
ON THE POINTS.
CROWDER IS THE THREE FOR
TONIGHT.
>> LIV JUST DROPPED A SCOOP
FORALL, CROWDER IS THE THREE.
IS THAT A LOCK OR NOT?
LET US KNOW IN THE COMMENTS.
FINALLY, WE HAVE CP3.
YOU GUYS KNOW HOW I FEEL ABOUT
CP3.
WE CALL HIM THE POINT GUY.
TO RECORD TEN OR MORE ASSISTS
TODAY.
THIS ONE IS NOT PLUS MONEY, LIV,
IT'S SITTING AT MINUS 130.
DO YOU LIKE THIS ONE?
THINK THIS IS A LOCK OR NOT?
>> I DO THINK IT'S A LOCK AND I
THINK THAT'S EXACTLY WHERY IT'S
MINUS 130.
I LOVE THIS PLAY FOR CP3.
I THINK IT'S A LOCK.
DEVIN BOOKER IS BACK SO IF CHRIS
PAUL CAN TAKE A STEP BACK FROM
THE SCORING ROLE AND FOCUS ON
THE FACILITATING.
HE HAD 14 ASSISTS AGAINST THE
LAKERS IN THEIR LAST MEETING AND
THE LAKERS ARE CURRENTLY
ALLOWING THE SIXTH MOST ASSISTS
TO THEIR OWE POINTS.
CHRIS PAUL, CP3 IN THE IF SF
FACILITATOR ROLE AND PLITS 10
PLUS TONIGHT AND IT'S A LOCK.
SFW
>> I'M THERE WITH YOU.
I'LL PUT THE HAMMER IT IN AND
DRILL IT INTO YOU GUYS' HEAD,
THIS SAY HIGH-SCORING AFFAIR.
WITH THE HIGH-SCORING AFFAIR
THERE'S A LOT OF BALL MOVEMENT.
CP3, I SEE HIM GOING OVER TEN
ASSISTS AS WELL.
I'M GOING TO LOCK THAT IN.
LET ME SEE WHAT THE PEOPLE ARE
SAYING.
I GOT CJ PRINT SAYING CP3 LOCK
FOR ASSIST.
THE LAKERS DEFENSE IS TERRIBLE.
I COULD NOT AGREE WITH YOU MORE.
DREA IS IN THE COMMENTS, LIV,
SAYS EASY LOCK, EASY LOCK.
SHOUT OUT TO EVERYBODY I
MENTIONED.
YOU ALL ARE WALKING AWAY HOWITH
HOODIES.
LIV, IT'S THE BEST TIME OF THE
SHOW, THE TIME THAT EVERYBODY'S
BEEN WAITING FOR, IT'S TIME TO
BUILD THE BR BETTING CUSTOM
PARLAY WHICH YOU, YES, YOU AT
HOME CAN RIDE ALONG WITH US ON
FAN DUEL.
FAN DUE SELL DOING SOMETHING A
LITTLE SPECIAL, LIV, THESE DAYS,
TELL THEM WHAT'S UP.
>> YES, FAN DUEL IS NOW GIVING
YOU THE CHANCE TO WIN EVEN
BIGGER ON YOUR SAME GAME
PARLAYS.
YOU CAN COMBINE BETS FROM
MULTIPLE GAMES INTO A SAME GAME
PARLAY PLUS.
THAT IS THE NEW NAME.
SAME GAME PARLAY PLUS.
GET ON FAN DUEL, CHECK IT OUT.
YOU KNOW WE ARE ALL ABOUT
CASHING OUT AROUND HERE SO THIS
IS A PERFECT OPPORTUNITY TO DO
THAT.
SO HEAD OVER TO THE FAN DUEL
SPORTSBOOK AND GET IT STARTED.
>> GET IT STARTED IN HERE.
YES, LET'S GET IT STARTED.
TONIGHT I'M BUILDING A SAME GAME
PARLAY FOR INDIANA VERSUS MIAMI
AND I NEED EVERYBODY, AND I MEAN
EVERYBODY TO GET IN THE COMMENTS
AND TELL ME WHAT THEY THINK.
WHICH LEGS ARE, AND WHICH LEGS
ARE NOT.
LIV, ARE YOU READY?
>> I AM READY.
I WAS BORN READY.
LET'S GET INTO IT.
>> LIV'S READY.
I'M READY.
Y'ALL ARE READY.
LET'S JUMP RIGHT INTO IT.
FIRST LEG OF THE PARLAY, WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT MALCOLM BROGDEN TO
GET 20 POINTS TONIGHT.
PLEASE, PLEASE, PLEASE TELL ME
YOU LIKE THIS ONE.
>> [ SIGHS ] A LITTLE NERVOUS
ABOUT THIS LEG, NOT GOING TO
LIE.
A LITTLE NERVOUS.
ONLY AVERAGING 16 POINTS IN TWO
GAMES AGAINST THE HEAT THIS
SEASON, AND THE HEAT RIGHT NOW
ALLOWED THE FEWEST OUT OF ANY
TEAM IN THE LEAGUE, THEY ALLOWED
THE FEWEST POINTS TO THE
OPPOSING POINT GUARD POSITION,
SO A LITTLE NERVOUS FOR THIS
ONE.
BUT IF HE DOES HIS JOB AND TAKES
ADVANTAGE OF A HEAT TEAM THAT
HAS A LOT OF GUYS OUT, HE SHOULD
BE ABLE TO HIT IT.
I'M TREADING LIGHTLY WITH THIS
ONE.
>> I LIKE THE "BUT."
YOU WAITED VERY, VERY LATE TO
DROP THE "BUT."
THEN YOU GAVE YOUR TAKE.
DUNCAN ROBINSON, MOVING ON.
HOPEFULLY THIS ONE CAN MAKE YOU
FEEL MORE COMFORTABLE, LIV.
ROBINSON THREE-PLUS
THREE-POINTERS.
DO YOU LIKE THIS?
MAYBE NOT?
MAYBE SO?
YES?
NO?
>> I DO.
UHM, I DO LIKE THIS ONE AND I'M
GOING TO TELL YOU WHY.
OBVIOUSLY HE IS A THREE-POINT
SHOOTER WITH JIMMY BUTLER AND
BAM ADEBAYO OUT.
HE HAS FOUR THREES AGAINST THE
PACERS THIS YEAR BUT I'LL BE
HONEST AND FULLY TRANSPARENT,
ROBINSON IN THE BUBBLE WAS A
DIFFERENT BREED OF BASKETBALL
PLAYER FROM THE THREE AND WE
HAVEN'T SEEN THAT SINCE.
SO I GET A LITTLE BIT NERVOUS
BETTING ON HIM.
HE'S BEEN A LITTLE INCONSISTENT
FOR ME.
I HAVE BEEN BURNED A FEW TIMES
ON DUNCAN ROBINSON.
REALISTICALLY, THEY SHOULD HIT,
SHOULDN'T HAVE ANY PROBLEMS.
HE'S HAD FOUR IN BOTH GAMES AND
THE HEAT ARE OUT IMPORTANT GUYS
THAT LIKE TO SCORE, SO HE'S
GOING TO HAVE TO HIT THIS IN
ORDER FOR THE HEAT TO HANG IN
THIS ONE.
I ALWAYS SWEAT A LITTLE BIT WITH
ROBINSON, JUST A LITTLE.
>> YOU HAVE A REALLY, REALLY
GOOD POINT BECAUSE IN THE
BUBBLE, THEY WERE COMPARING
DUNCAN ROBINSON TO KLAY
THOMPSON.
I HAVEN'T SEEN ANY COMPARISONS
LATELY BUT THEY WERE COMPARING
THE TWO AT ONE TIME, BUT
HOPEFULLY DUNCAN CAN HIT THREE
FOR US TONIGHT BECAUSE HE'S
GOING TO BE GETTING A LOT OF
ASSISTS.
A LOT OF ASSISTS FROM OUR GUY
WHO IS UP NEXT IN THE PARLAY,
KYLE LOWRY EIGHT PLUS ASSISTS.
ARE YOU ROCKING WITH KYLE, YES,
NO?
>> I LOVE THIS LEG OF THE
PARLAY.
I LOVE IT.
HE HAS HAD DOUBLE-DIGIT ASSISTS
IN THE LAST TWO GAMES HE PLAYED
AND WITHOUT JIMMY BUTLER AND BAM
ADEBAYO WE'VE SEEN HIM STEP INTO
THAT LEADERSHIP FACILITATOR
ROLE.
HE'S PRIORITIZING SCORING LESS
AND LESS AND BEING A FACILITATOR
WHICH SEEMS TO BE WORKING NOR
HEAT TEAM AND HE NEEDS TO
CONTINUE TO DO THAT TONIGHT IF
THEY WANT TO HANG IN WITH THE
PACERS TEAM.
I LOVE THIS PLAY.
I THINK IT IS USING THE "L" WORD
SCARES ME SOMETIMES BUT I THINK
IT'S A LOCK AND HE SHOULD HIT
THIS WITHOUT A PROBLEM.
>> AND LIV DOESN'T LIKE TO USE
THE "L" WORD.
THAT'S FUNNY.
I'MA TRY TO GET YOU SAY THAT
MORE BECAUSE YOU TOLD ME YOU
DON'T LIKE TO SAY IT.
THE LAST LEG OF THE PARLAY, LIV,
THIS ONE I REALLY, REALLY LOVE.
I LOVE THIS ONE A LOT.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT MY GUY,
DEMONTEZ SABONIS, TEN-PLUS
REBOUNDS.
I KNOW YOU LIKE THIS ONE.
>> LOVE THIS ONE.
LIKE IS NOT BIG ENOUGH OF A
WORD.
ANYTHING WITH SABONIS AND
REBOUNDS I LIKE.
I HAVE MADE SO MUCH MONEY
BETTING HIS PROPS, POINTS PLUS
REBOUNDS OR REBOUNDS STRAIGHT
UP.
I LOVE THIS PLAY.
HE'S HIT THIS IN FOUR OF THE
LAST FIVE.
HE AVERAGES 14 REBOUNDS IN TWO
GAMES AGAINST THE HEAT THIS
SEASON.
IT SHOULDN'T BE A PROBLEM.
I LOVE IT.
>> SHOULD NOT BE A PROBLEM FOR
MY GUY DEMONTEZ.
LOVE THE VIBES FROM LIV.
NOW, LET'S SEE THE TICKET.
LET'S SEE THE TICKET.
LET'S SEE WHAT WE WILL BE MAKING
IF WE WAS TO PUT 100 DOWN,
WALKING AWAY WITH 483, LIEI I L
THAT PLUS 485.
WHAT ARE YOU GRADING THE BR
BETTING PARLAY?
>> LET'S GIVE IT A SOLID B
MINUS.
YOU'RE STILL PASSING THE CLASS.
I'M A LITTLE NERVOUS ABOUT
BROGDEN.
ROBINSON IS HIS OR MISS.
WHEN HE SHOWS UP, HE SHOWS UP
AND WHEN HE DOESN'T, IT'S LIKE
HE'S SLEEPWALKING SOMETIMES BUT
I DO LIKE THE LEGS.
THEY SHOULD HIT.
I GIVE IT A B MINUS, PASSING THE
CLASS, A GOOD PARLAY AND THE
LAST TIME I GAVE A B MINUS, IT
CASHED SO WE'RE GOING TO ROCK
WITH THE B MINUS THIS TIME.
>> I MEAN, WE LIKE TO TAKE YOU
OUT OF YOUR COMFORT ZONE, LIV.
TAKE YOU OUT OF YOUR COMFORT
ZONE, GET YOU FEELING A LITTLE
BIT UNCOMFORTABLE AND LAST TIME
WE DID THAT, YOU GAVE US A B
MINUS, WE WON SO I DON'T DISLIKE
THIS B MINUS.
I DON'T DISLIKE THIS B MINUS AT
ALL.
LET ME GET INTO THE COMMENTS,
BECAUSE THE PRODUCER JUST
WHISPERED IN MY EAR, GIVE AWAY A
JERSEY.
SO GUESS WHAT?
I'M GIVING AWAY A JERSEY AND I
SEE A.J. BEERNAUGHT, HE GAVE US
A B PLUS FOR THE PARLAY.
HE GAVE US A FIRE EMOJI SO GUESS
WHAT, AUSTIN, YOU ARE WALKING
AWAY WITH A JERSEY OF YOUR
CHOICE.
THANK YOU FOR STICKING AROUND
AND THANK YOU FOR GIVING US THE
B PLUS AND THE FIRE EMOJI.
I'M BACK INTO THE COMMENTS, LIV,
GIVING OUT HOODIES NOW.
RICHIE21 IS HERE AND SABONIZ,
LOWERY AND ROBINSON, I THINK HE
HITS IT TONIGHT.
THOSE ARE GREAT VIBES RICARDO.
I'M GIVING YOU A HOODIE.
I GOT ONE MORE IN ME, GQUINN26,
I GOIVE AN A MINUS.
BROGDEN MIGHT NOT GET 20 POINTS
BUT THREE OUT OF THE FOUR WILL
HIT FOR SURE.
APPRECIATE YOUR GOOD VIBES.
BEAPPRECIATE YOUR GOOD VIBES,
BUT BROGDEN IS GONNA HIT AND
WE'RE GOING TO PUT THAT INTO THE
ATMOSPHERE.
WE'RE GOING TO MANIFEST THAT.
GUYS SEND ME SUNSETS IN THE
COMMENTS.
>> GOOD VIBES.
>> WE NEED GOOD VIBES.
>> GOOD VIBES ONLY.
>> GVOs.
MIKEY SAID IT BEST, A LOT OF
GVOs.
WE ASKED YOU IN THE APP, GUYS,
WHO YOUR BEST BET TO WIN IT ALL.
GET IN THE COMMENTS AND TELL US
WHAT DO YOU THINK.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE CURRENT
ODDS.
LIV TALK TO THE PEOPLE, TALK TO
ME, WHAT DO YOU LIKE HERE?
>> I GOT TO TELL YOU, I AM
LOVING THE NETS RIGHT NOW, BEING
AHEAD OF THE WARRIORS.
IT'S GIVING THE WARRIORS BETTER
VALUE.
I'M STILL RIDING WITH THE
WARRIORS TO TAKE CARE OF
BUSINESS AND LISTEN, THIS NETS
TEAM HAS TOO MANY QUESTIONABLE
VARIABLES.
I MEAN WE'VE GOT KYRIE IRVING IN
CONVERSATION TO JOIN THIS TEAM
AGAIN.
I'M NOT SURE HOW THAT'S GOING TO
THROW OFF THE CHEMISTRY.
WE'VE ALREADY GOT JAMES HARDEN
SAYING HE DOESN'T KNOW HIS ROLE
ON OFFENSE.
NOW YOU ADD ANOTHER BALL HOG TO
THE MIX AND TRY TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT OFFENSE LOOKS LIKE?
IT TERRIFIES ME.
I'M LOVING THAT VEGAS LIKES THE
NETS RIGHT NOW IN THE LEAGUE
BECAUSE IT'S GIVING US BETTER
VALUE FOR GOLDEN STATE.
I WOULD ABSOLUTELY TAKE THE
WARRIORS AT PLUS 600 BECAUSE I'M
NOT SURE THE VALUE IS THAT GOOD
AGAIN.
I GRAB IT AT PLUS 600.
>> THAT'S A GREAT, GREAT POINT.
WE KNOW KLAY IS COMING BACK,
WEISMAN IS COMING BACK.
WE DON'T KNOW IF THE ODDS ARE
GOING TO STAY AT PLUS 600.
I'M GOING TO HOP INTO THE
COMMENTS THOUGH.
I WANT TO KNOW WHICH WAY YOU
GUYS ARE LEANING.
LIV, I'M IN THE COMMENTS.
MY GUY LOSOGBALL SAYS THE BULLS
IS TAKING IT ALL.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, LOSO, WALKING
AWAY WITH A HOODIE.
BIGFACECOFFEE20 SAYS THE MIAMI
HEAT, JIMMY BAM OLIDIPO, SHOUT
OUT TO YOU, WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
LIV, I SEE LANDON, GAVE HIM THE
HOODIE EARLIER BUT LANDON IS
SPAMMING US BECAUSE HE KEEPS
PUTTING GSW.
THAT STANDS FOR THE GOLDEN STATE
WARRIORS AND I'M GOING TO STOP
GIVING AWAY HOOD EAST, EVERYBODY
I MENTIONED YOU'RE WALKING AWAY
WITH A HOODIE BECAUSE LANDON
MENTIONED THE GOLDEN STATE
WARRIORS.
LIV, YOU MENTIONED THE GOLDEN
STATE WARRIORS AND YOU KNOW
THAT'S MY PICK BUT I WANT TO
FOCUS ON THE NETS HERE.
LET'S PULL THE GRAPHIC BACK UP,
BECAUSE I WANT TO FOCUS ON THE
NETS.
THEY'RE SETTING THAT PLUS.
THEY'RE SETTING THAT PLUS 260
AND WE DON'T KNOW IF KYRIE'S
COMING BACK.
LIV, YOU TALKED ABOUT CHEMISTRY.
YOU TALKED ABOUT THEM PLAYING
WITH EACH OTHER.
JAMES HARDEN DOESN'T KNOW HIS
ROLE.
KYRIE WE DON'T KNOW IF HE'LL
PLAY HOME GAMES OR NOT, WE DON'T
KNOW IF HE'S GOING TO PRACTICE
IN NEW YORK OR NOT.
LIKE JUST THINK ABOUT THE
PLAYOFFS.
THE PLAYOFFS GET REAL
INTERESTING, GET REAL DOWN TO
THE NITTY GRITTY, AND CHEMISTRY
IS GOING TO BE NEEDED IN ORDER
TO WIN IN THE PLAYOFFS AND THE
NETS, THEY JUST HAVE SO MANY
QUESTIONS AROUND THEM.
THEY HAVE SO MANY QUESTIONS
AROUND THEM SO IT'S HARD FOR ME
TO LAY PLUS 260 ON THE TEAM WITH
SO MANY QUESTIONS.
THAT'S, JUST DOESN'T CLICK IN MY
HEAD.
SO SOMETHING THAT DOES CLICK IS
THE GOLDEN STATE WARRIORS
SITTING AT PLUS 600 AND WE HAVE
TWO STARTERS, TWO OF THEM, NOT
ONE BUT TWO STARTERS COMING BACK
INTO THE FOLD, SO I LIKE MY
CHANCES WITH THE PLUS 600, LIV.
LET ME ALREADY HOPPED INTO THE
COMMENTS BUT I WANT TO HOP BACK
THERE AND SEE WHAT THEY'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
YEP, THEY'RE ROCKING WITH THE
WARRIORS.
I GOT H SAYS WINNERS ONLY, GO
GARDEN SAID TRADE KYRIE.
LAKERS DARK HORSE, DON'T COUNT
OUT LIBIZILL, HE'S STILL THE
KING, DON'T SLEEP.
SHOUT OUT TO EVERYBODY I
MENTIONED.
YOU GUYS ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE BESIDES GO GARDEN.
THE PRODUCER JUST WHISPERED IN
MY EAR HE HAS 50 HOODIES SO GO
GARDEN WE CAN'T SEND YOU A
HOODIE.
MIGHT SEND YOU A JERSEY, I DON'T
KNOW.
I THINK THAT'S THE END OF THE
SHOW, LIV.
TIME TO GET ON UP OUT OF HERE.
THANK YOU GUYS FOR TAPPING INTO
THE GROUP CHAT PRESENTED BY FAN
DUEL.
REMEMBER WHAT YOU LEARNED TODAY.
THE PHOENIX SUNS, LOS ANGELES
LAKERS 3x2 IS A LOCK.
WE'RE RIDING THAT.
GET ON FAN DUEL AND TELL THE BR
BETTING SAME GAME PARLAY AND BET
YOUR OWN SAME GAME PARLAY PLUS.
THE DUBS ARE WINNING IT ALL, ME
AND LIV, WE'RE ON THE SAME
WAVELENGTH WITH THAT AND ALSO
DROPPING A SPECIAL CHRISTMAS
EPISODE, SO CHECK IT OUT AND
CHRISTMAS EVE RIGHT HERE IN THE
BR APP.
IF YOU WANT A HOODIE TODAY, WE
WILL DM YOU.
ALONGSIDE LIV, I'M GREG IVORY.
ME AND LIV WE LEAVIN' THE GROUP
CHAT.
PEACE.